Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys,
and today, we have a sprinkler.
Little sprinkly boy.
A little sprinkly boy
that you'd probably find
on the ceiling of a public place and that.
Or in movies.
Or in a movie, yeah.
Most people have seen one of these go off,
probably in a movie, or in real life,
if you've been slightly unlucky.
But, not everyone knows
exactly how they work,
so with the use of these bad boys,
this one,
and this one,
we'll show exactly how
they work in slow-mo.
These are not light.
Yes.
I'll put them down now.
Yeah.
All right, Dan, how do these work, then?
Essentially, what happens is,
you've got a fire in a
room, it's all burning hot,
all the heat rises to the ceiling,
where your sprinkly boys are.
And what happens is, this little
glassy juicy ampule here, the
juice in the ampule expands,
due to the heat, and
that smashes the glass,
which then lets the water flow through,
and hopefully douse the fire.
And this particular one we've got here,
will hopefully explode
at about 68 degrees C,
or 155,
American things.
Yeah.
Fahrenheit.
Fahrenheit, there you go.
We'll start off here at
1,000 frames a second in 4K
before going a little bit
faster to get that glass break.
You want goggles?
I have got goggles, yeah.
I'll go, I'll put them on.
Should probably stick 'em on, yeah.
Okay, we don't have a fire in the garden,
so I'm just gonna use this blowie.
Oh, oof!
Jeez.
It works very well.
Damn.
Flippin' heck.
Oh, the gas.
That was quite shocking.
Oh, it was, I wasn't
expecting it that quick.
It made like a right popping sound.
Poof.
It goes like, "Poof".
Damn.
Bosh.
Oh, it kicked back, you
see the whole pipe go up.
Yeah, it just like,
it was like a gun going off,
the whole pipe shakes.
Hell of a release.
Your face.
The way the hose is set
up in the pipe, it's like,
The thing is,
because it's so water-tight,
like, there was a little
bit of air in the tube.
Yeah.
So it like,
and then it went, "Oh,
okay, now we're good."
Okay, now we're going
for a cheeky top-down.
Sort of like ceiling view.
Yeah.
Yep.
Okay.
Say when I'm in position of the
unfortunate fool in the fire.
And the only difficulty is I
have is aiming the blowtorch
away from the camera.
Come in like this.
Okay.
Say when I'm aimed at the thing, okay?
You ready?
Yep.
Oof!
Oh, the...
Whoa!
Oh, no.
All right.
Woof.
It's very shocking every time.
It is, every time.
I can't help but, like, make a noise.
I tried not to that time.
Drogs around everywhere.
There's so much air in there.
Yeah, oof.
I feel like if you installed sprinklers,
the fire would be fanned severely
before being put out.
All right,
it's not my job, okay?
Look, that was a really good one,
you can see clearly that the,
like, the fans of the sprinkler
are causing that pattern of
water to go out everywhere.
Yeah, it's just the metal shape
that causes such a wide spread.
It comes out, like, in a nice torrent,
and then it pees out
everywhere to the sides.
It's good design.
So I didn't realize, it's not just
the glass ampule that goes.
This is one that hasn't been fired,
and this is one that has.
When you look down this here,
you can see there's a big hole
where the glass ampule was.
On this one, there's like a
whole metal surface that is there.
Ooh.
So I think the ampule,
actually, like, holds
the metal surface in,
and then when the ampule breaks,
the, like, metal disc drops
and allows the water through.
Okay, for the next shot, we
need a much higher frame rate,
so we've borrowed this bad
boy from Destin, the v2511,
and if you've seen this camera before,
you'll know it has very loud fans, so,
sorry about that.
Okay, we're now looking around this area.
28,500 frames a second,
you gotta bag the camera,
'cause it could get a splash.
Oooh!
Whoa.
Yeah, it gushes out there,
straight after the red goes,
and the red goes flying.
Yeah, you can see the amount of force
that blasts that thing down.
Yeah, it's like a torrent of water
after the glass ampule bursts.
Yeah.
It's like,
it pushes the little plate down,
and then it's like a
full-on torrent comes down.
The torrent is much wider,
it's a much thicker
stream than I'd imagined.
I thought it'd be a much finer stream,
but it's like, poof.
So did I, I mean,
we're learning about how these work,
and, like I showed you,
the plate that sits there,
but the glass ampule
breaks and lets loose,
just completely falls away and allows
loads of water to be free.
Yeah.
All right, now a much lower resolution,
we're at 103,000 frames a second.
Oooh!
Flip.
Gets me every time.
Ooh.
Yeah, it's almost like
the pressure bursts it,
but we know it's the liquid
heating up and expanding.
And the red liquid comes
out, like, sideways
and then the torrent just goes downwards,
so it's like two completely different,
you see the red, it's just
come outwards completely,
like it was that powerful a burst.
Whoa!
A bit of air in the tube, there.
Yeah, a little bit of air.
It's mystifying.
Ooh.
It, like, geyesered it, didn't it?
Yeah.
And then it comes down in a
steady, hefty torrent then.
It really kicks up, and it
has a lot of recoil on it,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
It's odd to see water moving that slowly.
Oh, so that's who's been
eating my damn hammock.
I think it is,
he's stood next to the evidence as well.
Returned to the scene
of the crime, have ya?
Look at what you've done.
It's pretty cute, though.
I forgive him.
Could make an episode
of "Planet Earth", here.
All right, see ya.
After feasting
on the hammock, the possum leaves,
leaving it in tatters.
That was 79 dollars down the drain.
I think he's left some
poo in the garden as well.
Well, it's not often
that I actually get to
use a blowtorch, and that
causes me to get wet.
That's true.
Yeah.
Also a little, sort of, red
speckles all over your face.
Oh, really?
Yeah, I think you got
some of the glycerine.
I don't think that's good.
That's probably bad.
Not ideal.
I think it's like, not lead-free.
I like videos like that.
I like it where, you sort of learn it,
you can visualize exactly how it works,
and now, I'll never look
at them the same way.
I can put on the smug voice
if anyone tries to ask me, I'll be like,
"Actually, I think you'll find
it's the ampule of glycerine causes
the expansion-"
"Ampule" is a great word.
It's underused.
"Ampule".
Yeah.
And now, because you've experienced five
explosions of glass ampules,
you'll be less shocked
if they go off for real.
I don't think I will be.
No, you won't.
I definitely won't be.
Based on today's video.
Ooh!
Ooof oof!
Hopefully, you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to bung us a subscribe,
that probably doesn't do anything.
Hit the bell as well,
if you want, that might.
We've also got social
media and a second channel.
Links in the description,
thanks for watching.